this is a look into the future with
Google's dream Fusion what you see here
are three-dimensional scenes many of
which are of singular objects but a few
more like an entire scene now of course
in the video playing they appear to be
just videos but they are not these are
actual 3D objects that you can interact
with or import into some other
application if you wanted immediately
things like video games and VR come to
mind for use cases but there are also
avenues like simulators for more AI
training for example because what we're
actually looking at here is the ability
to generate unlimited unique 3D assets
one common issue with simulators for
things like AI is assets for pedestrians
walls roads Etc everything they're
fairly limited like usually less than
100 unique ones and many AI wind up just
simply overfitting to recognize those
assets in particular killer and this is
just one example use case even just for
enjoyment and immersion into video games
and VR for humans this would also be I
think a very welcomed technology and
again this is just one use case of being
able to recreate or generate 3D scenes
so where does this come from it's a
recent paper out of Google called dream
Fusion text to 3D using 2D diffusion
in the paper the authors aren't using
imagen which is Google's diffusion model
notably they are using the 64 by 64
pixel resolution based Fusion model
instead of the larger variant and this
is due purely to the current processing
time that's required to do this
at least for me locally when using an
implementation from Ash hockey on GitHub
called stable dream Fusion Link in the
description of course I found an RTX
8000 to take about 30 minutes per 3D
representation going from 64 by 64 to
something like say 512 by 512 or even
larger might indeed be quite the
nightmare on current power and
performance but if Nvidia keeps tripling
performance every couple of years we
probably won't struggle much longer to
have even High Fidelity high quality
assets
someone will also probably likely find a
better cheaper to process technique to
achieve this same outcome but even so
the you know AAA type of budget for
games and stuff like that I think this
is already pretty reasonable to generate
High Fidelity unique uh Assets in this
way if you do wind up using the stable
dream Fusion GitHub do note that they
are using stable diffusion rather than
Imogen since stable diffusion isn't
actually open and available to use by
the public model and this is how I've
shown the examples like this one where
I'm actually interacting with 3D
Generations basically anything other
than that first video and kind of the
examples that were shown on the dream
Fusion website and in the paper
everything else is something that I've
generated from stable dream Fusion which
is a different back-end model now while
there are obvious limitations here I am
personally just like blown away by this
technology for the simple reason that
these are 3D representations from a 2d
diffusion model and those 2D diffusion
models can generate just about anything
that you can dream of and that is wild
to me so both in terms of what this
means going forward into the future but
also for like the Ingenuity here to to
make this happen the approach used is a
Nerf or neural Radiance Fields variant
with Nerf essentially you raise our
casts and pixels are generated one by
one to recreate scenes from new and
novel angles combining them for what
appears to be a 3D representation but
it's not quite that instead it just
allows you to move the camera position
around and get a new representation what
dream Fusion is aiming to actually do is
create a real 3D model itself rather
than just pixels that might represent
that 3D model Beyond this and also of
note Nerf is only possible when you have
many ground truth prior images at
various camera angles to feed to the
model the original Nerf paper used
amounts like 100 images which isn't you
know a ton but it's also not nothing and
you can also you can get away with less
but something like 25 images is
considered to be very few so you need
something like 25 to 100 images of some
object or scene at various angles so
then this means that not only do you
need this object or scene to already
exist and have physical access to it you
have to design that scene you've got to
take the photos you've got to
pre-process things and so on it's a
fairly arduous task what technology like
dream Fusion represents is the ability
to just imagine in full 3d similarly to
how we can just imagine entire scenes
and things that just simply don't even
exist in 2D with the major diffusion
models like stable diffusion and Dolly
and that is the major difference between
dream fusion and something like Nerf and
why this is just so exciting and it just
hugely impactful
it's possible that eventually we might
have decently sized text to 3D data sets
or something like that but I think it
will always be the case at least for the
next few probably decades that we will
have orders of magnitude more text to 2D
image data than text to 3D data so I
think models like this are the near
future for 3D generative models but I
also suspect and hope that we get
techniques and or Hardware that process
this a little bit faster so we can do
things even with higher Fidelity
comfortably
now what's even more wild is to think
about how you know very recently around
exactly the same time as this work meta
AI released make a video AI which
produces text to video in similarly as
all these other things unlimited and
unique fashion now pause for a moment
and consider that the almost inevitable
future is there will be text to 3D VR
like video that's coming that's there's
no question of if it's just only when
in the text to video models that we're
already seeing they're really just
predicting the next frame based on input
text and previous frames there's no
reason why these video models could not
predict next frames based on other
inputs also being included so things
like user actions so it might be a
combination of maybe there was a text
input but it could also just be previous
frames and user actions and now we are
deep down the rabbit hole what will be
possible in the next decade is truly
staggering to me to really think about
uh I think that again I think the
technology already exists right now to
have text to video and or just video or
you know user inputs to video I mean
that already exists now and we are
really fast approaching the capability
of having a sort of 3D simulator that
really could be truly indiscernible from
reality yet also entirely unique and
dynamic in its like possibility so I
mean these are this is like it's not
just like VR video games simulations
it's kind of is like it's not really
alternate reality but but it could sure
feel that way and that's I don't know
that's that's a tough one to to to
Grapple with given how fast things are
advancing right now I think it sounds so
wild to have those words come out of my
mouth but at the same time it's not
crazy based on the technology and the
way things are going and the rate at
which things are going right now
um
it's wild so I guess it's no surprise
that meta who is trying to lead the
charge with this idea of the metaverse
is the one pushing the boundaries here
with things like text to video and stuff
like that but meta AI are not the only
ones doing this and similarly to there
being an open source variant of dream
fusion and open source variant of Dali
there are open source variants of text
to video being worked on right now so
let me know Down Below in the comments
if you want me to cover one of those in
the near in the near future because I
probably will
for this dream Fusion you can play with
the technology yourself with the
previously mentioned stable dream Fusion
GitHub a few things to note is it does
appear at least to me that the overall
quality of what you get from the output
is it's just inferior to the ones
presented in the dream Fusion paper
not really possible for me to know like
how Cherry picks were those examples in
the dream Fusion paper so either way
this is these are like one of the very
first attempts at this sort of process
of doing text to 3D with with the
basically background engine being a 2d
diffusion model so I think a few more
attempts down the lines we will probably
see significant ironing out of many of
the details maybe get better results and
probably also go faster
in the original Dream Fusion paper they
also seemed to enjoy using text prompts
involving the use of the phrase DSLR
photo of blank and then they did this in
various combinations like DSLR photo of
a dog and then like zoomed out DSLR
photo of a dog and wide angle DSLR photo
of a dog since stable dream Fusion is
using a different model in the back end
which is stable diffusion instead of
Imogen like the original paper the best
phrase the best prompt to use is still
likely unknown in just plain untested I
personally found that using the prompt
phrasing of a rendering of seemed to
produce the best results but this is
just my super limited testing and there
are probably better ones honestly for
for both of these models that are just
yet undiscovered
as previously mentioned as well
generation time for each prompt was
about 30 minutes on an RTX 8000 and this
process seemed to want about 12 gigs of
vram but I'm not sure if it's doable
unless and it was just using 12 because
it was there
the main issues I encountered besides
the kind of degraded uh output that I
kind of feel like there just is compared
to the paper uh was just outright and
total failure where the generation was
like a mirror like cloud of nothingness
or where the representation was
multi-faced which is termed the Giannis
Problem by the researchers at Google who
came up with dream Fusion so we'll see
if there is a fix there but I think
that's actually an open-ended problem at
the moment anyway very cool research
that I wanted to share with you all and
just an exciting time to be in this
field there are lots of advances still
for me to cover so stay tuned for those
if you've ever wondered and wanted to
know more about how neural networks
actually work including the optimization
and fitment rather than just simply
calling some method then you might be
interested in checking out the neural
networks from scratchbook by myself and
Daniel kukiyawa the book can be had in
the form of an ebook PDF softcover or
hardcover and we ship for free worldwide
also the physical books just come with
an ebook copy all copies are in full
color which helps because there's a lot
of code syntax highlighting and lots of
charts and diagrams to help convey the
principles also almost all of those
charts and diagrams have QR codes and
links that take you to animations to
help further illustrate the concepts
this is truly a real neural networks
from scratch teaching everything from
the forward pass calculation of loss
back propagation and optimization the
only math that you're expected to know
coming in is basic algebra the rest is
taught by us in the book step by step
everything is shown and explained in the
book first logically then mathematically
then via raw python code no third-party
libraries and then finally optimized via
numpy and this is for every step of the
way building and training actual neural
networks for a fully fundamental
understanding of neural networks and how
they work from scratch if at any point
you're lost or confused all copies of
the book also Grant access to a Google
Docs version of the book where you can
ask your questions in line with the
actual text itself this is an incredible
project that I'm extremely proud of to
share with you all we've sold over 13
000 copies to students all over the
world if you're looking to take your
knowledge of deep learning to the next
level or if you're just looking to start
that Journey I can't imagine a better
way so to learn more and buy yourself a
copy you can head to nnfs.io